A lot of time has passed since Stargate SG-1
ended its run in 2007.
Like most fans, you're probably wondering
what happened to the actors from the series
since their days at Stargate Command.
Here's what they're up to today.
Few actors have the honor of playing the main
role in one successful television show, let
alone two, but Richard Dean Anderson is a
member of this short list.
Anderson played the beloved protagonist of
the hit series MacGyver in the '80s and early
'90s.
In 1997, he returned to television as Colonel
Jack O'Neill in Stargate SG-1.
O'Neill is pulled out of early retirement
when the Stargate device is activated and
aliens come through attacking Air Force personnel.
After a rescue mission, O'Neill becomes the
commander of the military unit Stargate SG-1.
The team explores new planets through the
Stargate with the hopes of attaining new technologies
and allies.
They need to put together a team capable of
defeating the powerful and sinister Goa'uld,
who intend to enslave humanity.
O'Neill frequently cracks sarcastic jokes,
even in dire situations, often bringing an
appreciated dose of humor to an otherwise
serious character.
Despite his comedic side, O'Neill takes his
job very seriously, often risking his life
to save his unit.
He is also deeply haunted by the death of
his young son, who accidentally shot himself
with O'Neill's pistol.
After eight seasons, Anderson stepped down
as the main character and took on a smaller
role during the last two seasons as a guest
star.
After the conclusion of the Stargate SG-1
franchise, Anderson left the spotlight and
only appeared in a handful of TV show episodes
here and there, his last appearance coming
in a 2013 episode of the sitcom Don't Trust
the B in Apartment 23.
While Anderson has attended several conventions
over the last few years, he largely remains
quiet about his personal life and has essentially
retired.
Amanda Tapping played the intelligent and
overall exceptional soldier Samantha Carter
for all ten seasons of Stargate SG-1, as well
as the two following Stargate movies and the
spinoff series Stargate Atlantis.
Carter frequently struggles between choosing
a military career and a more scientific route.
She's often the brainiac that explains alien
technology and phenomena to the audience.
And she’s usually at odds with Jack O'Neill,
who wants things simplified.
The show frequently teases a romance between
O'Neill and Carter, but the two are never
able to express their feelings due to military
protocols.
"Normally neutrinos pass through ordinary
matter now matter how dense.
I mean, something like five hundred million
billion just passed through you."
"No Matter how dense…"
Tapping continued acting, as well as directing,
after her Stargate years, and her talents
are evident both in front of and behind the
camera.
She starred in the sci-fi series Sanctuary,
as Dr. Helen Magnus and even directed quite
a few episodes.
Tapping played the recurring character Naomi
in The CW's Supernatural.
She’s even directed several episodes of
popular TV shows, including The Flash, Dark
Matter, The 100, Travelers, and The Magicians.
Tapping remains very active and has plans
to continue directing, her most recent work
serving as an executive producer and director
for the supernatural TV show Motherland: Fort
Salem.
Michael Shanks played the civilian archaeologist
Daniel Jackson, who originally argued that
the Egyptian pyramids were built by aliens.
When the SG-1 team assembled, he joined hoping
to one day rescue his wife Sha're, who had
been possessed by an alien parasite.
While possessed, Sha’re ruled with her "husband"
Apophis as galactic dictators.
Though Jackson doesn't have military training,
he can still hold his own, and often brings
archaeological and cultural expertise to missions.
It doesn't hurt that he knows over 30 languages.
Jackson is the yin to O'Neill's yang.
O'Neill is mission-minded and understands
the importance of obtaining technology to
defend the human race.
Meanwhile, Jackson wants to befriend and understand
all alien races even if they don't have technology
to offer.
This sets up a lot of internal conflict on
the team, though the two are always good friends
at the end of the day.
Shanks was in every season of Stargate SG-1,
but only had a guest starring role in season
six.
He remained a very active actor after the
Stargate franchise, starring in the medical
drama Saving Hope as well as appearing in
several TV series such as 24, Eureka, and
Burn Notice.
More recently, Shanks joined the television
series Altered Carbon as recurring character
Horace Axley.
Christopher Judge played the alien Teal'c,
who was once the First Prime for the evil
Apophis.
Teal'c defected and helped the main characters
escape Apophis.
He ended up swearing allegiance to Earth,
joining SG-1, and trying to free his people,
the Jaffa, from the clutches of their cruel
masters, the Goa'uld.
Teal'c is comically serious, and often misunderstands
human lingo.
"Lucy, I'm home!"
"I am not Lucy."
"I know that."
He's an incredible tactician, often outwitting
enemies on the battlefield, and a very loyal
friend.
Unfortunately, his ethnic and cultural differences
often create conflict with upper military
personnel who question his loyalties.
On top of it all, he often finds that these
same military brass want to "study" him to
learn more about aliens.
Judge went on to have a successful career
outside of Stargate, appearing in popular
TV shows like NCIS: Los Angeles and The Mentalist.
Judge had a minor role in The Dark Knight
Rises and he was in the very campy movies
Mega Shark vs. Mecha Shark and Sharknado 3:
Oh Hell No!
What you may not know, though, is Judge has
a very impressive voice acting career, particularly
in video games.
Most notably, he played Kratos in the popular
video game God of War, but you can also hear
his distinct voice in games like StarCraft
II: Legacy of the Void, World of Warcraft:
Warlords of Draenor, and World of Warcraft:
Battle for Azeroth.
There was a large shift in Stargate SG-1 between
seasons eight and nine.
Richard Dean Anderson took on a minor role,
leaving a big hole in the team we came to
know as SG-1.
To fill that slot, sci-fi veteran Ben Browder
stepped in as the new team's leader, Cameron
Mitchell, for the last two seasons of the
show.
Browder had previously starred in Farscape.
He commanded a presence similar to the one
Anderson had on SG-1, both as a strong military
leader and someone who could bring a laid-back
atmosphere to the screen.
Mitchell is less sarcastic than O'Neill and
a little more optimistic and good-natured.
Naturally, Mitchell's first challenge is smoothing
things over with a disjointed SG-1 and getting
along with all the other characters.
Like so many other talented actors from the
series, Browder went on to have a successful
acting career, appearing in TV shows like
Doctor Who, Arrow, Chuck, CSI: Crime Scene
Investigation, and Criminal Minds.
Browder also played the Sovereign Admiral
in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2, and has
done a little voice acting for video games,
including Call of Duty: Black Ops III.
It's been some time since we've seen him in
a leading role, but Browder remains active
today.
In its later seasons, Stargate SG-1 featured
two actors from the sci-fi show Farscape.
Ben Browder stepped into the male lead vacancy
left by Richard Dean Anderson, and Claudia
Black played Vala Mal Doran.
Believe it or not, Doran was originally planned
as a one-off character in season eight of
SG-1.
Doran returned in seasons nine and ten as
a main character and even appeared in the
two movies The Ark of Truth and Continuum.
Playfully mischievous and infatuated with
Daniel Jackson, Doran brought a dash of fun
and moral ambiguity to the team.
She joined Stargate Command in the fight against
the Oriwho are the new villains in seasons
nine and ten after the Goa'uld are defeated.
Since her Stargate days, Black has continued
acting in television.
She’s taken on the recurring role of Dahlia
in the fantasy drama The Originals, and a
main role in the drama Containment as Sabine
Lommers.
Black has also done a lot of voice acting
for video games and animated shows.
You can hear her voice in Diablo III, Mass
Effect 2 and 3, Gears of War 3, Final Fantasy
XIV, and the celebrated animated comedy Rick
and Morty.
"This will be the first instance of capital
punishment in our society in 500 years due
to our awesomeness.
So we are forced to improvise.”
She continues to act in television and do
voice work.
Recently, Black played a role in the sci-fi
drama Roswell, New Mexico.
Corin Nemec played a rather unique role as
Jonas Quinn, an alien from Langara.
Initially, Quinn was a minor character but
ended up becoming part of the main cast and
a member of SG-1 in season six.
Michael Shanks, the actor who played Daniel
Jackson, left the show during season six over
creative differences, leaving a hole in the
main cast.
As much as SG-1 fans loved Jackson, Quinn
helped fill the void.
Nemec portrayed Quinn as a scientist who brought
a quirky and fun spirit to the team.
He was an immediate hit.
Michael Shanks decided to return to SG-1 in
the following season seven, which made Jonas
Quinn a minor character again.
Corin Nemec continued acting after Stargate
SG-1 and remains active today, with a filmography
that includes guest roles on television shows
like NCIS, Supernatural, and Ghost Whisperer.
In 2013, Nemec suffered an injury on a boat
while filming Poseidon Rex.
His leg was shattered and required surgery,
but afterward, he healed and continued performing.
In addition to acting, Nemec occasionally
writes and directs TV shows and documentaries.
Most recently, Nemec started touring the United
States filming a documentary called Love America
Tour, which focuses on unifying themes among
Americans.
Teryl Rothery played the beloved medical examiner
Janet Fraiser, who faced the unimaginable
task of healing soldiers suffering from alien
diseases and wounds inflicted by alien technology.
Basically, it's a whole new frontier of medical
science for humans, but she handled it with
wisdom and optimism.
Despite staying behind the front lines, Fraiser
occasionally saw some action.
She went into the field a few times and also
had to deal with foothold situations in Stargate
Command.
In season seven, the character died in combat,
although Rothery briefly returned to the series
playing a parallel version of her character
in season nine.
In addition to acting in over 70 episodes
of Stargate SG-1, Rothery acted in several
well-known TV series, including Eureka, Supernatural,
Caprica, and Arrow.
While she typically appears in sci-fi and
supernatural-themed TV shows, she's also taken
a few roles in traditional dramas, particularly
on the Hallmark Channel, including Cedar Cove.
More recently, Rothery appeared in the sci-fi
comedy show Upload and continues to play recurring
roles on The Good Doctor and Virgin River.
Tony Amendola played the memorable Master
Bra'tac, the wise warrior who taught Teal'c
everything he knows.
Bra'tac is a retired military Jaffa on his
planet, but continues to secretly train others
because he plans to start a rebellion against
the Goa'uld, who are the slave masters of
the Jaffa.
Bra'tac is a bit of a father figure to Teal'c
and is an important connection between the
Earthlings and Jaffa.
While these two species are technically on
the same side fighting the Goa'uld, they often
have cultural differences.
And there's also the awkward fact that they've
both killed each other many times since the
Jaffa are the soldiers for the Goa'uld.
After Stargate SG-1 ended in 2007, Amendola
continued landing various roles in television
and also started voice acting in video games
and animated series.
He played a minor villain in the dark mystery
show Dexter, starred in the sci-fi series
Continuum, and had a recurring role on Once
Upon a Time.
Amendola also appeared in CSI: NY, The Mentalist,
and Numb3rs.
In addition to a successful career onscreen,
Amendola also has an impressive voice acting
career.
You can hear his voice in video games like
Star Wars Jedi: Fallen Order, Final Fantasy
XV, Fallout 4, World of Warcraft: Legion,
and Call of Duty: Black Ops III.
He continues to act, mostly in television
or lending his voice to video games.
Peter Williams joined the ensemble cast of
Stargate SG-1 as the appalling Apophis, who
would serve as the main antagonist for the
first half of the show.
Not only is Apophis a tyrant that enslaves
and murders humans, but he also has a unique
connection with several of our beloved characters.
Teal'c served under Apophis as his First Prime
before defecting to Earth, but naturally,
those days haunt Teal'c.
It doesn't help that Apophis exiled his wife and child, and enslaved his people, the Jaffa.
Apophis also took Daniel
Jackson's wife, Sha're, as a host for his
queen.
When he needed a host for his son, Apophis
kidnapped Skaara, who is like a
son to O'Neill.
After playing the sinister Apophis, Williams
continued acting primarily in television,
appearing in the early 2000s Twilight Zone
revival and Fallen.
Williams continues to act, mostly in television,
and recently took on a role in the sci-fi
series The Expanse.
Don S. Davis played the altruistic General
George Hammond.
He's a loyal, no-soldier-left-behind leader
and frequently goes to bat for SG-1, even
when they break the rules.
Despite his strong leadership, Hammond has
a bit of a soft side.
His two granddaughters are number one on his
speed dial, above even the President of the
United States.
Unfortunately, Davis didn't live long after
the end of Stargate SG-1, passing away in
2008 at the age of 65.
At the end of the seventh season, Davis stepped
down as a regular actor on the show for health
reasons and only appeared as a guest from
then on.
Despite slowing his career down a bit, Davis
continued booking small-screen roles like
so many of his fellow cast members.
He appeared in the pilot episode of Psych
and the video-game-turned-movie Far Cry.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.